Wow substitute teacher aesthetic app hi
guys my name is grace if you knew that
you are great if you didn't know that
you have potential to be great none of
us know how to do life which is why life
hacks are so necessary and so popular
I've watched a lot of life hack videos I
know how to put eyeshadow on a piece of
tape and transfer it to my eyelids I
know to take my warm laptop and put it
on my ovaries so that I can mute the
pain in my coop but there's some stuff I
haven't seen in life hack videos yet
which brings me to my top 10 life hacks
that everyone must know i 100% guarantee
you that these life hacks will make your
life different if you use them got a
shirt you want to wear but it's too
wrinkled and you don't enough time to
steam or iron out all those wrinkles
before an important meeting don't worry
just throw the shirt in the garbage and
then throw your phone in the garbage and
live in your closet for the rest of your
life ever been in this situation where
you find yourself in need of toilet
paper but there isn't any don't worry
just use your sock that's on your foot
and then throw it out the window for
good luck ever been ready to walk out
the door but notice the deodorant stain
on your shirt don't worry just take your
stick of deodorant and draw some
horizontal stripes on the shirt no one
will know and you'll even smell like you
showered ha ha joke's on them ever had
super gross hair but no time to brush it
not even a second don't worry just take
an empty toilet paper roll and tie it
straight into the top of your head no
one will notice that you got dirty hair
now ever done your makeup but you still
can't seem to get rid of that unwanted
sit don't worry just get a pair of
stockings or pantyhose
and put them over your head and let
everyone know you're on your way to
shoot a collab video with another
youtuber ever been really hungry eat
something
ever realized how gross your fingernails
are but you don't have enough time to
get a manicure don't worry just dip your
fingernails into tuna no one will notice
those gross overgrown cuticles now your
hands smell gross ever been really
self-conscious about the odor of your
own feet don't worry just go out in
public with a full-length mirror in
front of you when someone thinks that
they are smelling an odor from your
direction and they look in your
direction they'll see their own feet in
the mirror and then they'll realize that
the odor might be coming from them ever
felt really immature and irresponsible
don't worry
get a dog having to keep that alive will
kick-start some responsibility pronto
ever need a misleading thumbnail for
your video and fast don't worry
throw on your favorite tank top and pull
the shoulders down just far enough so
that looks like you're naked then make a
series of overly dramatic reactionary
faces and boom you got a thumb now well
there you go there my 10 life hacks that
everyone should know now you know but
please remember with great hack comes
great back bonus hack when I get away
with saying say back so yeah in your new
life I don't know give this video a
thumbs up if it's something that you
enjoyed or if it's something that you
didn't enjoy give it a thumbs up if you
felt anything during this video even if
you felt nothing that's feeling to
thumbs up all of you please forever life
hack if you give this video a thumbs up
you make it into the gates of heaven I
don't know you can't disprove that so
and subscribe lord knows what that does
for you lord
the singer she knows she knows it
changed her life so I gotta get out of
here